[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
il y a un meurtre en série
je veux que ton point de vue
premier anniversaire soit du papier
ce qui te fait penser que je suis si bon marché
je pensais que tu serais curieux
penses tu que j'ai coupé dans ce
truc non  toi
tu as des photos
[Applaudissements]
c'est de la violence c'est tellement fauché
il aime les petits puzzles n'est-il pas
si ridicule
merci tu as planifié ça toute sa
vie
je sais qui il est
oh
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il était
c'est un personne ne
veut être quelqu'un
qui est  le maire
le commissaire
ouais
il a de l'ambition
tu penses que son motif est politique oh
non c'est très très personnel
il a l'impression que ces gens l'ont tous
enregistré il
remonte probablement des
blessures non cicatrisées volé beaucoup d'argent
pourquoi m'écrit-il
peut-être
qu'il est fan de toi
ou peut-être qu'il a aussi une rancune contre toi
peut-être que tu es le plat principal de
toutes les théories
oh ouais vraiment
tu es normalement si sans tête
mais quelque chose est différent
cette fois
c'est très bouleversant pour toi
revenons à lui pourquoi
tu es tellement m  plus amusant je ne suis pas ici pour
parler de moi de quoi êtes vous ici pour
parler je veux savoir comment il pense que vous
savez exactement comment il pense avez vous lu
ce fichier
vous avez tellement en commun des
aventures masquées
donc il est encore plus juste
avez-vous peur qu'il vous rende doux en
me faisant perdre mon temps d'
accord
je vais vous dire ce que je pense vraiment
je pense que
vous ne vous souciez pas vraiment de ses moteurs
s'il vous aime ou vous déteste
je pense que quelque part au fond de
vous vous êtes juste terrifié
parce que vous  Je ne suis pas sûr qu'il ait tort hein
tu penses qu'ils le méritaient